[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and as you
probably already know apple held an
event this week their usual september
event where they only announced two
things
not an iphone and not an iphone so once
we collectively got over that you know
it will be a dedicated iphone 12 event
likely sometime in october but what we
did see at this one was new apple
watches and new ipads now it's tech
timber so we're gonna get to it all
eventually but what i do have here for
you is a first look
at apple watch series 6 and also we'll
touch briefly on the new apple watch se
so this is everything that's new and
lucky for us it's pretty simple
now the new stuff actually starts with
the unboxing where you're going to get
mostly the same packaging as a previous
generation apple watch but this time
you'll notice besides the watch itself
and the band it comes with half the
charger is missing so it comes with the
cable that you need but no usb wall
adapter and that's now sold separately
and apple notably tacked that into the
environmental section of their
presentation kind of like i predicted in
my video about how the iphone 12 will
probably also
not come with a wall adapter to save
money i mean to save the environment
from all the e-waste caused by them
consider this lack of a brick in the box
basically writing on the wall for the
next iphone anyway then you get to the
watch itself and aesthetically on the
outside the only real change that you
will notice is the colors and that's
because that's the only real change on
the outside the materials are the same
the sizes available are the same but you
do have some new colors now there's blue
gold
graphite and yes this product red that
we have here
now i personally still like to do my
accent colors with the band more than
the watch itself i've always had a black
apple watch and like i don't think i'd
want a red apple watch all the time like
every single day but hey maybe you can
rock that maybe you can make that choice
if you want to some people could i could
see wearing the blue like every day it's
not so bad but it looks familiar new
color that's simple and then on the
inside really the tech improvements are
the new s6 chip and a couple new sensors
so the s6 chip really feels like apple's
silicon team continuing to make strides
flexing on us again they've always been
really good with efficiency and they've
made another step in that direction here
so it is a dual core chip in here based
on the a13 bionic and thanks to an
improved efficiency it'll let them crank
up the always-on display to be twice as
bright as the series 5 and keep the same
battery and performance and i've been
messing around with this for just a
couple hours on watchos 7 and i do think
they've tightened up a lot of the
animations so it actually feels faster
snappier because the animations are
shorter but really i think that was the
goal is to keep the battery life at a
day and a half because that's important
that's what it's been for so long and
now the watch does sleep tracking so
people really need to find the right
sliver of time in the morning to charge
it up and not have it die and the series
6 watch will actually now charge up
faster as well so it'll go from zero to
100 battery in about an hour and a half
which is
it's not blazing fast for anything but
it is an improvement it's better than no
improvement at all and of course most
things charge their fastest from zero to
like 75 percent so that'll be shorter so
then those new sensors i mentioned which
you can kind of see if you're looking at
the bottom of the watch or if you fire
it up and start to do a new measurement
and that's because there is a new blood
oxygen sensor so it's literally using
infrared photography to measure the
color and therefore the percentage of
oxygen
in your blood it's pretty wild i gave it
a shot i consistently get a pretty
normal reading which i guess is a good
sign now of course the stipulation is
it's not medical grade it's just kind of
there to inform you generally of where
you're at like you probably by yourself
won't think this is a reason to get the
apple watch series six but it's here and
it's cool that it works and then there's
some other quick hits five gigahertz
wi-fi support now in series six there's
also now an altimeter using barometric
air pressure to tell you your elevation
down to the foot which means it won't
work on planes but whatever could be
cool for hiking or skydiving or david
blaine but yeah that's pretty much it
for series six not that dramatic of a
difference but whenever you see new
colors on apple products people tend to
go pretty into it with the color stuff
and i can see people making a pretty big
deal about that so some of the bigger
apple watch changes that i've just kind
of been wondering about lately like when
are they going to do a different shape
like maybe a more round version when are
they potentially going to add qi
wireless charging support are they ever
going to do that to enable more
compatibility with other smart wireless
charging pads or maybe a future version
of air power
are they ever going to do truly open
third party watch faces and have a whole
watch face store
none of that big dramatic stuff is
happening with series 6. now i do like
that watch os 7 keeps slowly adding a
few more watch faces and there's some
more cool ones here again with
third-party plugins via complications
the way it's always been but again this
isn't like dramatically changing
anything you still have most of the
customization you'd be used to for an
apple watch refresh but maybe more
interesting than the watch itself
actually is these new bands they
announced so these these uh these are
some stretchy they call them solo loop
bands
and essentially they're the really clean
minimal
seamless bands that they've announced
alongside the series 6 watch and so
basically as you can imagine fitting is
really important with these so to get
the right one they have a fitting
document on their site you can print out
use a credit card to make sure you
printed the right size then you cut out
this loop and use this to wrap it around
your wrist to figure out your apple
watch size and then you can go in and
order your solo loop band in that size
and if all goes well then you can attach
both ends to the watch and you can put
it on just by stretching it over your
wrist every time instead of having to do
all the hard work of opening and closing
a velcro or a buckle i would say just
from my experience if you're if you're
between sizes i would say go for the
more snug one because it'll be a little
tighter at first and then you can break
it in and eventually get it your size
instead of one that's too big and then
just always a little bit too big but
those bands are going to be 50 to 100
bucks the braided ones here are 100
bucks so i probably wouldn't recommend
getting these but the 50 just clean ones
that are stretchy and clean i just like
stretching them uh pretty minimal and
the apple watch series six price is
staying the same but speaking of prices
i also should touch on there is a new
apple watch
se and that's starting at 279 which is
pretty sweet and as you can probably
imagine just based on the name the apple
watch se
is the new
old
new
apple watch
that makes sense right but we've seen
this formula before basically the apple
watch se is an apple watch series 5 more
or less there's no blood oxygen sensor
there's no electrocardiogram there's no
always on display
but for a lot of people who don't need
most of those things this is a great
deal for a watch it's much faster than
the series three it has the bigger
screen sizes from the new models and it
even gets an always-on altimeter so
that's a lot of smart watch for 279 i
can see this being one of the more
popular upgrades or even a gift i think
for people this holiday season which is
probably a big reason apple's deciding
to drop it now but there it is that's
pretty much everything you need to know
that's different about this apple watch
versus the others there's of course the
watchout stuff coming to all apple
watches there's of course the family
sharing stuff which is kind of
interesting low-key also appearing
across apple watches but hey if you
didn't already like apple watch this
won't change your mind if you already
loved apple watch this won't change your
mind you're still going to love it to me
i'm still in that mode where i'm
thinking about the more nebulous big
picture thoughts what are they going to
make a circle
that type of thing but either way let me
know what you think if this is the apple
watch for you
and uh that's pretty much it tech timber
is just gonna keep rolling thanks for
watching this one catch you guys the
next one
peace